للشهر السابع على التوالي وكاطولي فتره في
تاريخ لبنان الحديث يستمر اضراب القضاه
لاسباب معنويه وماديه
وطبعا التدفئه والتبريد والى اخره
والنظافه كله تقريبا مفقودين بقصور العرب
سياسيه بده يقول بالتدخل بالملفات
القضائيه مش بس الملفات الكبيره او
الخطيره او المهمه حتى صار يتدخلوا يعني
او يحاولوا يتدخلوا
بملفات حجمه صغير صار في الليره اللبنانيه
لدرجه انه رواتب الاوضاعات
انعدمتعجله وعاديه تقدم يوميا متوقفه بسبب
الاضراب المستمر
تتعلق سواء باوراق ضائعه بتتعلق بسريقات
ما عم يقدروا يقدمه هل شكاوى بالنيابه
العامه في دعوى بتتعلق باموال ناس مصالح
ناس همم تحويلات لبرا شوفوا بقى تستوعب
الاعداد الموقوفين اليوم عم بيوقفوهم بقلب
المخاطر وبقلب اماكن لا تليق بالانسان
واكتريتها الموجودين بقدونس هتتعلم لحتى
يطلعوهم يعني
570 القادم موزعون على ثماني محافظات
لبنانيه يطالبون بتحسين وضعهم المعيشه
والمعنوي والا فان الاضراب مستمر لتضاف
اشكاليه جديده تهدد حياه ومصالح المواطن
اللبنانيه